you don't just create a story you also
create Stars you know you also give
people an opportunity to shine on the
screen and I would love to know what you
look for in these performers that you
think will I mean as it does
successfully convey the feelings that
you're trying to get to the people and
I'm trying to uh find people who are
ready to do their the the their greatest
role you know and in that perfect place
so I I very much I'm so I'm so thankful
that you know the Daniels and the Kikis
of the world will come out and do it but
I'm also looking for somebody who is is
really smart enough to take over the
character for me I do the work to build
this character up to a certain point and
then I need somebody to come in and
become the expert so I can ask them how
does emerald feel and she can she can
answer that question we can kind of move
from there and so you know I I just I
have a very I have the privilege of
working with people like uh like Daniel
and like Kiki who are just you know the
the best actors in the world